the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode
okay hi everybody it's mike from order
flows and welcome to today's
presentation on
digging deeper into order flow and
in this training i'll be talking about
uh
making sense out of the flows you know
the flows that come into the market you
know market's always trading
and it's not a static organism it's a
constantly evolving
um environment that understanding what
is happening in the order flow is going
to help you
understand what's happening in the
market and make better trades
i'll be talking about advanced order
flow analysis
and lastly i'll be talking about how to
find edges and opportunity
within the order flow you know that's
what everyone always says you have to
have an edge in the market to be
successful but then
you know they never teach you or really
explain how to find your own edge
and i'll be talking about edges that i
use in the market
in my trading in my analysis and
hopefully you can take some of that away
and apply it to
your own trading now
why order flow you know a lot of people
think that order flow
is you know is is a new thing you know
it just sort of happened in the last uh
you know the last 10 years or last 15
years but you know it's really not you
know order flow analysis has been around
for
a long time and you know one of the
greatest books on trading
by you know what people consider one of
the greatest books if you've ever read
market wizards you know a lot of the
guys that are in market wizard says
um you know the the book that had the
most influence on them as traders
is reminiscence of a stock operator and
the trader inside that he was
someone that read the order flow he was
a tape reader we used to call them tape
readers because in the old days
you know guys would be in the broker's
office watching the ticker tape
that was a form of order flow analysis
and
what makes order flow different than
other forms of technical analysis
is it gets you as close to what's
happening in the market
right now you know you're not looking at
a moving average that's smooth over
you know the last 21 periods 50 periods
200 you're looking at what's trading
right
now and making decisions based off that
you know you're going to understand
how the current trading activity what is
happening right now in the market how
that's
impacting the market and how it's
causing
the market to move right and lastly you
know
orderful gives you an edge over other
traders by seeing things
that they just don't see right a lot of
traders aren't looking at the order flow
and you know imagine you know it to me i
explain it to people like
imagine playing cards with you know your
your group of buddies
but you're the only one that's able to
see all their cards
right they can't see your cards but you
can see what they're doing you know
imagine how
that would improve your your card game
but you know imagine it in a trading
sense how that's going to improve
your trading you know it's it's almost
like
you know if you play sports right if you
play um football or basketball you know
having the other teams play books so to
speak
you know you could understand what
they're going to do next
because you understand how they are
playing just as
you know understanding how traders are
going to react based on what they're
doing
right now and best of all you can make
this happen
without past trading experience right
you don't need to sit in front of your
screen for
10 000 hours trying to figure it out you
know i'm going to show you how to do it
really easily
you know you don't need big mathematical
formulas you know
now everyone thinks oh you know i could
just solve
the markets using math well you can't
right otherwise the markets would have
been solved a long time ago
you don't need complicated technical
analysis right you just need common
sense
you don't need macro fundamental
analysis you don't need to know
what the weather in the ukraine is going
to do for the wheat crop and how that's
going to affect wheat exports
etc etc you don't need that you don't
need algorithmic trading tools
right you don't need to sit down there
and do all this coding and and
you know spend hours and hours a day at
the machine trying to
come up with some algo to solve the
markets and you don't need programming
skills right because i'm going to show
you you know how you can look at the
market
based on software that's already out
there now
for those of you that are new to one of
my presentations my name is michael
volatiles right and
i've got over 25 years of professional
trading experience okay but
i just you know i'm not doing this you
know to sort of put myself up on
i just want you to understand where i'm
coming from and
why what i say makes sense is because
this is what i did for a living right
i did i traded with order flow at these
firms
for a long time right i started on the
cme floor with dean witter reynolds back
in the
the early 1990s right i left the trading
floor when electronic trading started
becoming a thing right because you know
before it was just like uh you know no
one really cared about what was
happening
overnight but i saw that the future was
going to be
electronic and i left the floor i think
it was in 1995
and i started working up on the
electronic trading desk at dean witter
eventually i left there to join edf man
which is a big english trading company
right they've been around since the 17
late 1700s after that i left there to
join commerce bank in chicago as
a licensed urex trader right back in
those days
to be able to trade on urex you needed a
license from the exchange you know and
is is
it's a big thing it's not like this
simple series three or series seven this
one's more intense right you gotta
do all this answer all these questions
about options and all that stuff
you know math out to the the third or
fourth decimal place not just
choose simple multiple choice it was
very complex
after commerce bank i was there during
september 11th
and after september 11th i took about
six months off you know i sort of
reassessed my life
then i joined cargill in chicago cargill
is a big
u.s commodity trading firm and
you know it's a private company so not a
lot of people really heard of them
unless you know you're a farmer because
they account for about 30
of grain exports about 25 of wheat
and i'm sorry of meat exports livestock
but they tried everything everything
imaginable um around the world
and when the exchange in singapore was
closing
they cargill wanted to set up a
off-the-floor
trading desk so they sent me out to
singapore to set up their trading desk
and then after about two thousand 2005
i the part of cargill that i was working
for got sold and i joined uh
jp morgan in singapore i was vice
president of futures trading i spent
eight years there
and you know it was literally on the
trading desk trading you know i'd come
in at about 5 30 in the morning for the
a.m globex open which was the 5 you know
p.m reopen of globex and i would be
there
until about five in the afternoon which
by that time london was already open and
we could pass our
our trading book over to london and i
left jp morgan in in 2013
and i just wanted to trade for myself
right i want a better quality of life i
don't want to spend all my days in the
office
all my hours you know i had a family you
know
you get to a point where you know if
you're successful if you're good at
trading
you can trade for yourself right and i
was at that point in my life you know i
was
comfortable being able to support myself
in trading
and i started writing a book on trading
with order flow
and eventually the software that i was
using with order flow i wasn't happy
with right i wanted
something more of the software i wanted
the software to do some of the analysis
for me so it would free me up to do
other things either look at other
markets
or you know other time frames as opposed
to being
glued to one time frame okay and
eventually in 2015 we released our order
flow software because a lot of traders
that i was talking to were seeing my
software saying hey
you know can i get a copy of that you
know and it was really just a modified
version
of a footprint chart that i was using
for my own self but other traders
wanted to wanted it you know and that's
how the order flows.com website
eventually started now this is not about
me though
right it's about showing you how
overflow can improve your trading
results quickly get you from point a
to point b as quickly as possible now if
you stick around to the end
i told you right i wrote a book on
trading order flow i'm going to show you
how to get a copy of it for free
it's going to be a download copy it's
not going to get
you're not going to get a copy of the
hard version but you can download it
it's 150 pages and
print it up now the charts and tools
that i use in this training
are generated from my order flow
software but what i'm showing you today
you can apply with other order flow
footprint software
but you have to know what to look for
right in the footprint that's that's
what i want to talk about today but
you'll be able to see how quickly
and easily you can apply order flow
analysis to your trading
to make better more informed trades now
you know just brief disclaimer please
understand trading
involves risk don't trade with money you
can't afford to risk
making sense out of the flows right when
people talk about flows
you know there's sort of two schools of
thought all right people some people
will say well
actual order flow is what's traded on
the time and sales
or some people will say well no you got
to watch the depth of the market to see
the order flows
well they're both right in a sense
okay when you look at the time and sales
right the one on the
left that's what's actually traded in
the market the one on the right the
depth of market
just shows you the orders that are
working um you know
on the bid or on the offer which is
constantly changing people are
constantly pulling their bids
uh moving them up or down you know
changing their offers adding more taking
out some
it's constantly changing but the dome
the depth of market
really just shows you the intentions of
traders right because
you know it you used to have this well
there is this phrase
um cancel if close right sometimes you
see a big order in the market
and the market starts slowly getting
there and then it boom it just
disappears right the person canceled it
if
as it got close because you know maybe
they're trying to sell it at 33.40
but the market starts ticking up you
know we're trading a point lower market
starts trading 25s halves three quarters
also the person trying to sell out of 40
oh i could sell it better at uh
at a half right and they move it up so
it just shows people's intentions as
opposed to
actually what's traded right what's
trading what you see going through on
the time and sales but time and sales
move so fast
faster than the dome moves you know the
average trade in the e-minis
is about you know two contracts more or
less
so you can imagine every trade that's
going through you're seeing one one one
two two
one one two two it's it's very difficult
to make sense out of
now most traders view the market with
candlesticks
okay and there's nothing wrong with
candlesticks i used to use candlesticks
you know when i was beginning to trade
right
i thought candlesticks were the greatest
thing ever honestly
um you know i could see wow you know it
gives me a visual representation of
what's happening in the market
different than just a normal bar chart
right you know nowadays
especially people are more
visually attracted to things right you
look at facebook you look at instagram
um and those things right you just
scroll right through you just it takes
you
you can process a picture rather than
you know trying to read a whole post
like you would read on a blog right
and you know if you can see something
very quickly like like a candlestick
yeah that makes sense
however you're missing out a lot of the
information
right order flow traders right they
they're looking at
what's trading on the bid what's trading
on the offer you're still looking at a
candlestick chart
right because you know you still want to
know what the price action is doing in a
bar
but you also want to know what's being
traded at price
okay and it's important to understand
what's trading at a price because
if you've ever run a business right
you've ever sold anything on ebay
or etsy or on amazon i said or you have
your own business you understand that
how you adjust your inventory you adjust
it based off of
what you sell at prices right you
for example right if you're selling you
know the new iphones right say you have
a source to get the new iphone 12s at
wholesale prices okay i don't know what
it is now a thousand bucks or something
they're selling for
you start listing them up on amazon or
ebay
and you know occasionally you sell one
for you know thirteen hundred dollars
okay well
you can't sell all at thirteen hundred
dollars because you have
other people also selling it right so
you're going to adjust your price down
down down closer to where the market is
and that's why it's important when i say
you know order flow gets you as close to
the market as possible you can see
what's trading
how much is trading at a price okay
because
yeah we would all like to you know if
we're all selling iphones
we'd all love to sell them at fifteen
hundred dollars thirteen hundred dollars
but the reality is
maybe you're going to get one or two
trades up there right you're not gonna
be able to sell them right and then
everybody else is selling them at twelve
hundred dollars
and you're sitting there like an idiot
trying to sell it at fifteen hundred
dollars you're just not gonna be able to
sell any
so you know you have to take into
account
where the market's transacting at
and time and sales you can see that
right but it's moving so fast
when you're looking at the market and
you know you could be looking
you could have you know several hundred
trades going through in a second
and you're just not gonna make really
digest what you're seeing there
the depth of market it moves fast not as
fast as the time and sales
but the depth of market is almost like
watching a slot machine
it's like having a slot machine on your
desk because you're seeing the bids
changing the offer is changing getting
bigger getting smaller
um orders coming in you know those
trades going up you know jumping up
price jumping up two three ticks you
know moving down three or four ticks
it's just moving around so fast you get
excited and you know honestly
at least the people over trading
sometimes um you know because they see
the market moving oh i got i got to
participate i got to participate now
order flow right the volume footprint
takes all that information on the
the time and sales and on the dome and
puts it into a nice
easy to read format right what good is
having all that data
if you can't make heads or tails of it
right it's
it's it's pointless right but now you
can
right you can take all that information
format it into useful information
right you have new data points which
we'll be talking about in a second but
the footprint chart the order flow
footprint chart allows you to see
current value allows you to see market
weakness
lets you see support and resistance when
there's market sweeps
coming through the market when there's
imbalances right you know everyone talks
about you know markets move from value
are
basically two forms they're either in
balance or they're out of balance right
and it's going to be important to know
when
that's happening when a market is out of
balance because when the market's out of
balance
that's when it's moving market
exhaustion right you gotta know when
traders when the last trader has bought
one in the last trader has
sold right the market is just it it
can't move anymore in that direction
aggressive trading aggressive trading is
actually what moves the market right
when you have
people lifting the offer or selling into
the bids divergence right when
price and trading activity are going in
the opposite direction
and much more right order flow really
opens up a whole range of new forms of
analysis for
many traders
and it's confusing trying to figure out
what's happening
on the dome right you have aggressive
sellers selling to passive buyers you
have passive
sorry aggressive buyers buying from
passive sellers right and again you know
order flow in a nutshell
is about what understanding what the
aggressive traders are doing in the
market
but if you don't know what to look for
like i said it's
a it's kind of pointless to to stare at
it you know some people say well yeah
only you know
these prop firms will say well i'll sit
you down in front of a
dome for three months and either get it
or you don't
well why don't you get the training for
it you know i mean it's not like things
are going to come naturally to a lot of
people
some people think well i'll just sit in
front of the dome and watch it for a
year i mean
honestly do you have a year to spend
watching the dome honestly i'd rather
bang my head against the wall i've
watched the dome
you know since electronic trading
started back in the early 90s
and honestly it's boring um
you know watching your trying to figure
out what's happening
because what happens is you turn your
head away get a drink of water or look
at your phone
and you miss something okay so
it's i i just find it more useful to
have an order flow chart a volume
footprint chart to understand
what's happening in the market right to
me it sort of gives me a
sort of a step back and being able to
sort of put the pieces of the puzzles
together
now from the time and sales in the dome
when you organize that data
it allows you to see things in the
market but there's three
key points of order flow analysis that
stems from these three data points the
delta
which is the difference between the
aggressive buying and aggressive selling
in a bar
the point of control is the price level
in the bar with the most volume
and lastly is imbalances is when you
have aggressive buyers
outnumbering aggressive sellers by a
certain ratio usually it's four to one
but it's up to you to choose your ratio
or more and vice versa
right so you could have buying imbalance
you could have selling imbalance nope
just really quick delta is the net
difference between aggressive buying and
aggressive selling
aggressive buying registers as plus one
in the delta
aggressive selling registers as minus
one in the delta
now every bar has a delta it can either
be positive
means generally means aggressive buying
was in control
it could be negative which generally
means aggressive selling is in control
or it could be zero right could just
delta could just land on zero it could
be evenly matched
um you know sometimes people think well
you know delta zero must mean something
no it's just coincidence i think
in all my analysis whenever i see a bar
that has zero delta don't don't read too
much into it
and the strength or weakness of the
delta gives a trader clues as to what's
happening
in the market right now so delta
okay this is yesterday and most almost
all the charts i'm showing you are from
yesterday i got a few from this morning
and this is a five minute e-mini chart
and yesterday right we had that nice
sell-off okay and you can see here
right just after the cash open all right
8 30 it's the cash open here
you're seeing mostly negative delta i
only got one bar with positive delta but
you know minus 900 minus 360
bar with positive minus sixteen hundred
minus two hundred minus
three thousand minus two thousand and a
bar with my with positive a thousand
overall since the cash open delta's been
negative
all right there's been a lot more
selling than
buying going on so what do you think the
market's doing
right sellers are coming into the market
at these prices at this
34 26 27 28 29 level
right buyers are happy thinking you know
hey you know we're going up
right just as the market seems to have
been defying gravity all this time
but it's actually not sellers are
taking this opportunity to sell at these
high prices you'll notice
right we're not really going higher
we're just sort of going sideways
all right so you know there's even
though there's there's buyers here
coming into the market you know working
bids these sellers are like oh my gosh
this is a great selling opportunity
selling 16 over 1600 contracts more than
buying in
this bar over 3 000 more in this bar
over 2
000 more right then the selling sort of
it just sort of
dries up right here you got a bar
positive delta of a thousand
but the bar is not even can't even go
any higher right than
than your swing high here then the delta
you can see just turns
very strong negative minus 254
minus 2000 right as we take out that
swing low
and the market just drops boom right we
sell off quite nicely with 50 point
sell-off yesterday
now imbalances occur when aggressive
buyers outnumber aggressive sellers by
four to one
or more or vice versa okay so you could
have aggressive sellers
outnumbering aggressive buyers okay and
when looking at the actual volume
trading in the two-way auction
a trader can see if there's more
aggressive trading occurring right but
you have to look at a footprint to see
it you're not going to see it on a dome
because on a footprint it will print a
certain color
right on a dome which is gone right and
forget about looking at a time and sales
most of the time the two-way auction is
trading in relative balance
right but one of the signs of a market
starting to move
in a direction is when there are
imbalances present so for example
again this is yesterday cash open right
cash open okay we got a big
dump of orders coming in because it's
cash open it's monday all right so i'm
not
too concerned with the first few bars
generally of the cash open
but okay so you know we got some buying
balances there won't overlook that again
to say it didn't happen because it did
happen
but market doesn't go anywhere next two
bars later
bar with a lot of selling it balances
okay but then the next bar doesn't go
anywhere
we've got this green bar here with about
seven buying imbalances
yeah okay let's see what's going to
happen the market you know next bar
comes up starts training higher okay
that's a good sign
next bar even higher okay that's a good
sign but if you're watching the delta
it's still negative it's negative it's
negative
what you want to see when you're seeing
buying imbalances come in you want to
see the next bars
follow through right you want to see
positive delta you want to see more
imbalances you're not seeing that
then you come up here to a swing high
then here this bar you've got
a couple imbalances you know two
imbalances
honestly is nothing to get excited about
and we're just going sideways but we do
got some strong negative delta
and then this bar right here right we
break down through that
cash opening low right the initial
balance
we got about eight seven imbalances in
here right you got strong negative delta
that's what you like to see right next
bar also
starts trading lower right it takes out
the low of that bar
you got some more imbalances and you
also got negative delta
right and then you know the market will
takes out the low
takes out the next low next low and and
sells off
um 40 50 points all right so that's how
imbalances
can clue you into what's happening in
the market now point of control
is the price level in a bar with the
most volume
and the price level with the most volume
is important to know because
it's a balance area in the bar now
a lot of traders think well volume is
not important nah
yeah i don't care about volume but think
about it for a second
do you think a price level that trades
20 contracts should be
treated the same as a price level that
trades 2 000 contracts
no it shouldn't right and when you're
getting into things like exhaustion
it's going to be very very revealing to
you as a trader
by watching the volume right not all
prices are created equal
right not all traded prices are created
equal a high can trade
one contract and then
come off dramatically or it can trade
you know it's normal order flow there
and just sort of go sideways
right so volume is important don't let
anybody else
fool you so point of control
generally as the market starts moving
higher
right point of controls will migrate
higher right one
two three four five it's going higher
right then you sort of get into this
area where it goes
it's going sideways point of control
sort of line up here one higher
one lower but as
the market starts selling off we got a
point of control here at uh
27 then another one here at 24 and a
half
another one here at 16. mark the
point of controls are migrating lower
right and what's important to notice
is these pointed controls are are what
we call version point of controls right
they haven't been
touched in the next bar right there
they're sitting there right next bar
also lower hasn't been touched and again
that's another form of analysis i'm not
going to get into it right now
on this presentation but you know it's
something that
as a trader you have to pay attention to
so again you know this line here
34 17 is that
low of the cash opening period you know
the
you call it the initial balance low
takes it out all right got a lower point
of control
lower point of control just sort of
rotates around and then boom lower point
of control lower point control lower
point of control lower point of control
so you know that's how you can use point
of controls right
keep you on the right side of the market
right if you're short
right say you're long right so you got
long earlier right off of these two
point of controls
are these point controls migrating
higher right and you're along somewhere
in here 28
something and then it's point of control
one two three point controls
lower than your entry price that's not a
good sign
because what's happening is these lower
prices are being accepted
then you can see how it starts breaking
down lower point of controls lower point
of controls lower point of controls
just as you know if you're getting short
in here somewhere you know around the
3410 and point of controls are still
lower
that's good rather than being long up
here at 34
26 and the point of controls are coming
in at 34.25 right you want to be short
in those conditions you don't want to be
long
from above the points of control
or above the value right you want to be
short
above value or short above the points of
control
so now that you understand how to start
using the data points of
delta point of control and imbalances
it's time to take orderful analysis to a
step further
okay and it's part that i call advanced
order flow analysis now earlier
you know i talked about delta point of
control and imbalances
with that those pieces of data you can
start to see things like current value
market weakness support resistance
sweeping imbalance exhaustion
aggressive trading divergence now one
thing to remember when you're looking at
order flow software
it's not all created equal right that's
why i created my own
now you don't necessarily need my order
flows trader software to see what i'm
about to show you in the order flow
using software though that allows you to
see these marking conditions just makes
your trading easier
right it's it's it's a personal choice
you know sometimes people ask me mike
you know should i use your software
or should i use this other software this
other software well
it's really choosing a software that
you're comfortable with and more
importantly what the software does for
you right
i'm all about making things easier for
myself that's why
everything in my software is a tool
to help me initially first right
i mean it's also to help traders but
you know i trade right this is the
software that i use for trading
and what i put in there
is how i view the market what i'm
looking for in the market you know
a lot of people get interested in order
flow they watch videos on youtube or
you know well there's not really many
books on order flow except mine
but you know they want to get involved
in it but
they don't know what to look for and
that's why having
the software that makes the order full
does the orderful analysis just makes
life easier for you
now value okay what i want to talk about
now is value value is measured as the
price at which buyers are willing to buy
something and sellers are willing
to sell that's something at okay that's
what value is that's how you
you put a price on something
you figure out what is balances and the
value area right if you're familiar with
market profile or volume profile
you understand that's the area which the
majority of buyers or sellers are happy
to do business at
usually it's like sort of the the 70
percent of the volume
um for the day is you know the volume
profile for the day is
is that area they would consider that
the value area
and again you know most traders are
familiar with the value area in terms of
market profile or volume profile but
what a lot of people don't know is you
can view the value area on a bar by bar
basis which is going to give you insight
into volume analysis on a bar by bar
basis
that many other traders are just flat
out ignoring
right everyone always wants to talk
about price action i'm following price
action
but really what they should be watching
is value action
and value can be hard to see to the
untrained eye
right so this is just a normal footprint
chart
okay but
again a lot of traders think well i
could just put i could draw a profile
for each bar
right but honestly that's going to get
very messy especially if you're trying
to watch
the order flow you know you you i used
to have a chart
with the screen like this showing me the
value area for each bar
um and you know honestly i'm going back
and forth i was getting
you know it i was getting i was missing
things
honestly that i wanted to put a value
area on a footprint
so again it's nothing fancy it just puts
a box
around the value right the points of
control are still there that's the area
with
the most volume traded in the bar but
the value area is where 70 percent you
know some people say well it should be
68 you can change that right you can go
to the settings you can change it if you
want to
do it to 68 but honestly it's
not going to make much difference
between 70 and 68 um
generally but again it's up to you what
you want to use you can adjust that so
it's easy now i can see
where the value area is in a bar
right and that's important because now i
understand
is value is the price you know what
people perceive the price of the market
is that going higher
or is that going lower well people say
well can't you just look at price and
determine you know are we going higher
or lower
well one the reason i look at value is
because i want to see
i want to get a vision into the market
before
price starts moving making a move higher
or lower right
you can see here right we broke away
from
you know the 20 you know the the what 24
25 26 area right in here
and just dropped you know 20 points
right i don't want to be getting short
down here at
16 or 14 you know i want a clue
up here when we're still trading 23 24
25 26 as opposed to
10 points later right that's how i'm
gonna get my edge in the market and
knowing where value is trading is going
to
show me that so i can see here
yeah the market's going sideways okay
and
but i know i got overlapping value i've
got one two three four
five six basically six bars where
the bar you know the value is
overlapping okay then i got a little gap
in here
okay so that's a sign that hey you know
what we're starting to come out of this
consolidation we're putting in
a lower value area in here right between
what is that 25 and a half and 23 and a
half right so then the next bar
okay so i know that we're starting to
trade lower okay now a lot of people
what they'll do say well this is my
you know opening range you know this is
the cash open here or they'll draw a
line from like
you know 27 and this low here at uh
17 and a half and wait for a breakout
okay well
what happened here right we broke the
value area high or not the value very
high we broke the
opening range high here and then just
went sideways okay so if you're long
from in here
that's a bad long right because the
market is just
you get in and it just sort of sits
there rotates sideways but look at this
you have this gap in here
right this is again this e-mini
five-minute chart but again
whatever form analysis if you're looking
at a range based charts the same thing
looking at a time based uh one-minute
chart you know or
a tick based chart volume based chart
you'd be looking at
for the exact same things to happen so
you have a gap in here
and the next bar right we open up
we trade back into the value and start
rejecting it right that's your time
say hey you know what i should this is
my shorting opportunity here
rather than waiting for the market to
break down here at 17 right
break this low right because what
happened is
we opened up below value traded back
into it
starting to reject it and trade lower
that's your time to get short that's
gonna give you an extra five points on
this trade
before the market uh falls over now
that's that's value right understanding
where value is trading in the market
is is going to help you understand
what's happening
right now in the market again that's
what i'm talking about gets you as close
to the market as
realistically possible for making good
trading decisions
now market weakness is something that i
want to talk about and it occurs when
buying stalls or recedes on a move up or
selling stalls or recedes on a move down
buyers are getting lesser and lesser on
a move up means there's less chance
of the move continuing higher okay so
imagine the market's going up but then
there's less people buying do you think
the market's going to keep going higher
no it's probably going to stall go
sideways
and fall over because everybody that's
wanted to buy is already bought
there's no one left to do the buying
same thing as markets selling off
sellers are decreasing on a move lower
who's going to help the market to move
lower when the last
seller has sold nobody there's nobody
left to sell
and again if you're watching a normal
footprint chart if you know what to look
for
you can sort of see it in the market
okay so
always take what's happening in the
market in context put it in context
always got to be asking yourself
questions you know i always with my kids
with their schoolwork i tell them let's
play a game what do we know right when
they're sort of stuck on their homework
what do we know the same thing applies
to the markets right okay you're at your
high of the day
this was um the 22nd right this was last
thursday
okay market is at the high of the day
okay so what can happen one yeah we can
go higher or two we can
go sideways or three we can sell off so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
start looking at
the delta okay i could i could look at
value also in a second but
for me the delta is starting to be kind
of revealing it's kind of going both
ways right you got positive
negative positive negative positive
less positive even less positive than
negative
big negative the negative negative
negative and the market sells off
um you know a quick 20 points
so what do you think is going to happen
you still people say well still got
positive delta well you got positive
delta
your a few ticks off your high in this
bar
right delta has decreased from the bar
before it was 1800
now it's only 500 and it's a red candle
that's not a good sign
then the next bar it's got a lower high
a lower low and even smaller delta
right 346. and then this bar here
you know again another uh
lower low and lower high and big
negative delta at this
point you know it should be obvious that
you know this high you know the market
is weak up here it's there's no more
really buying interest buyer beware
buy at your own risk because
what you saw here you saw the buyers in
the delta the aggressive buyers
decreasing
getting weaker and then boom sellers
took over
all right and then we sell off from 32
all the way down to
you know below 10. but really the signs
were here in the delta now
you could also look at the points of
control
you got a point of control next one's
lower next one's lower next one's lower
it does pop up here
okay we'll see you have to see what
happens in the next bar
next bar lower so even if you're getting
in
you know maybe you say ah you know i'm
not convinced with this delta when you
look at the points of control coming in
they're lower right again value areas
you can see value areas
generally migrating lower except for
this one green bar then you got that big
gap in there by that point you should
already
the fact that we couldn't trade back up
into the previous bars value area is
is a negative for the market and
obviously the market sold off again you
know even if you got in very late so i'd
say you got in late here
at you know 24 25 okay
realistically you should have been in in
any of these two bars
right here um you know somewhere around
this
yellow line which is the opening price
for the day
now the having software
that will highlight to you when there's
market weakness is a good thing right
this is
again i just showed you how to look for
it on a normal order flow
volume footprint chart but on my order
flow chart we'll
we put these arrows tell you hey you
don't miss this there's market weakness
here now does that mean that anytime you
see an arrow
it's automatic buy or sell right if it
was bullish it would appear below
in a blue color no you still got to take
things in context and you still got to
pull the trigger right i'm not a big fan
of automating
everything there's certain things i like
to automate but as a trader you got to
trade right you want to put
the pieces of the puzzle together all
all the order flows trader software does
is analyze the order flows to you
and serves it up to you on a platter
whether you want to take the trade or
not based on
what market context right what's
happening in the market
now divergence in order flow occurs when
aggressive trading and price go in
opposite direction so when a new or
equal high
is made aggressive selling not buying
appears when a new equal low is made
aggressive buying not selling up here so
for example yesterday okay again five
minutes is the e-mini chart
we hit the low of the day down here at
and what do you see right you have a
divergence right that's this green arrow
right you got positive delta on the low
so
aggressive selling on the way down
positive delta
down here right all negative delta on
the way down
at each lower low you hit this new low
you got
positive delta right the market started
turning around right we turned around
because aggressive buyers
started taking control of the market and
you see how the market uh
started moving back up but just taking
divergence by itself is
is not always a good thing right you
also want to be watching what's
happening next in the market right
what you need to follow through order
flow to confirm
everything that's happened yeah i have a
divergence it's telling me okay mike pay
attention this market
could start to rally because now we're
starting to see aggressive buying but i
still got to watch what happens in the
delta so we went from 95
558 that's good 1800 yeah that's very
good right so aggressive buying is
getting stronger now
okay it's probably a safe trade to say
yeah if i get long in here right and if
you got long
that was a great opportunity to get long
next thing i'd be watching the
imbalances
okay is the next imbalance higher or
lower right if it's lower it's not a
good sign
it's higher that's a good sign right if
you're trying to get if you're getting
long
i'm sorry that's the point of controls
you also want to watch imbalances in the
bar
right the aggressive trading happening
in the bar and you can see there's one
two three buying imbalances in here
nothing in the next bar but the next bar
later you got
also three imbalances so that's good
right but
again just because you have a divergence
doesn't mean the market has to react
accordingly
you need order flow that flows
to be conducive right you need just
because you have a signal say get long
or get short
it doesn't necessarily mean the market
has to do that right because you need
other traders to also be getting long or
getting short you know
yesterday a little bit earlier right i
showed you yesterday's rally
but there was a time yesterday that i
want you to see this right
you have a buying bullish divergence
right here in the circle
but if you're watching again like i said
you got to watch what's happening okay
well we got a big buying coming in
positive 2 000 in the delta
then the next bar is still a strong
positive delta
1600 point of control is higher
you don't have any imbalances happening
in this next bar it's a doji bar closes
where it opens
you know this is those bars that as a
trader really
make life difficult right then obviously
the next bar
again knowing where the value is right
we open up in the value and just start
moving away from it that's not a good
sign
if you're long off of a divergence or
anything
right if we can't hold that value
or get through it to the other side and
you're you know if you're long here that
that's not a good sign
instead you know we open up in the value
quickly move out of it
that's not a good sign right so you know
poc obviously is is going to be lower
right if we can't even get back into
that value
so you know don't just think that oh my
gosh i got a divergence i got to start
i got to get longer and get short right
you got to put it in market context
right
and what you're seeing is first bar
strong delta
next bar yeah it's a strong delta but
it's weaker in the sense compared to the
previous bar
obviously the next bar is even weaker
10 okay market came right back up in the
next bar but then it just went sideways
right that's not what you want to see
take that relative to this bar here
it was positive delta then stronger then
stronger and stronger
right you want to see strength coming
into the market not that weakness
like you're seeing here where it's just
the buying is getting weaker and weaker
you know it pops back up but then it
gets weaker stays weak
and then just goes sideways on you this
was this morning
okay this was the high of the day at 34
10. and there's actually a couple
imbalances
this was the first one here at the just
after six o'clock this morning
there was one a little bit later around
6 40 but
if you're looking at this right we hit
our high
got your divergence and you see
negative deltas minus 62 minus 159
minus 91 and then some kind of small
deltas
22 negative 65 positive minus 15
4 72 83 just going back and forth but
look at that
even though it's you know relatively
small deltas it's mostly negative right
yeah obviously we sold off nicely from
that 3410 high
but the same thing happened earlier like
a little bit later i didn't screenshot
it but
um by about half hour after this same
thing right you hit the divergence on
the high when you hit 3410 again
and if you're just looking at the delta
you would see that
it's overall negative right before the
market sort of puked out
all right and again in here this is six
in the morning you're gonna get small
bars
um so you know you're seeing buying and
balancing selling and balances
it's it's a lot clearer during the
trading day the cash session
um what imbalances and pocs mean
but on bars that just have you know
trading three or four price levels
it's kind of honestly it's kind of
difficult to put together
a meaningful point of control analysis
now let's talk about how to find edges
and opportunity within
the order flow okay so
what separates winning traders from
losing traders
is not having an edge right what is an
edge it's a piece of information that
other traders don't have
or something they don't see happening in
the market right it gives you that
orderful gives you that edge because you
have that information other traders
don't have
for example you know back when there was
trading floors you know on the cme cbot
the reason why one of the reasons why
the exchange memberships were so
expensive is so people can stand there
and see
the order flow coming into the market
right it gives them an
edge over somebody that's sitting in an
office looking at a screen
and doesn't have they're seeing you know
goldman's or or solomon brothers
broker checking the market you know then
start selling a little bit and they're
thinking well if he's selling a little
bit maybe he's got more behind it and
they get short things
like that now order flow one of the
edges
that i find very useful
is recognizing things when a big order
hits the market
and you know people say well yeah i can
see that in imbalances but
there's another thing you can look for
it's called a market sweep now
what is a market sweep okay so for
example here this market's trading 33 39
even at 33 39 and a quarter offer a big
trader
is bullish right and he's aggressive
right he has a thousand contracts he
wants to buy
maybe because he knows you know the
stimulus is going to pass in
a couple minutes okay so i'm gonna i'm
gonna buy now right so
what's he going to do right he's going
to try and finesse it well i'll work
some on the bid
you know i'll buy i'll buy 25 now and no
it was okay i know something's going to
get passed you know stimulus or whatever
i want to get long buy a thousand right
he'll just buy everything up to a
certain price right he'll buy everything
up to 30
340 and a half and
he's not concerned with well i bought 98
at this price 133 at that price he's
just concerned with his average price
right when you're trading big size
you're really all concerned about is
your average price so
what's he do he buys everything up to 40
and a half
his average phil is 39
spot eight five and also in marcus
trading 40 and a half he's already in
the money
okay now sometimes you can see that on a
dome
that's if your eyes are glued to the
dome right and you notice it but
on a footprint chart you can see it
pretty easily
right you can see what's happening right
someone swept through the market here
this was this morning
right this was when we're trading 93 94
a big seller came in just you know
whacked the market right and
they sold the the 125 the 115 the 159
even turned it off for 144
right and then the market started
trading lower it came right back up into
that area where the big seller was maybe
the guy came back sold some more
and he had a nice sell-off but again
if you're trying to watch it on a dome
you're not going to see it right and a
sweep you know
think of it is someone who's buying
the current offer and the offers behind
it up to a particular level or sells
through the bid down to a certain level
and turns the market offered
so again just to reiterate if the market
is 39 to 39 and a quarter
what someone's going to do when they
sweep the market you know say they'll
sweep it up to
40 and a half so they'll buy everything
in there and turn the market
40 and a half bit all of a sudden you'll
see all of a sudden the bids filling in
down here
markets 40 and a half bid at 40 and
three quarters conversely if they sweep
the market to the downside
they sell everything from 39 down to
37 and three quarters turn the market
offered right here
also now the market's 37 and a half at
37.3 quarters offered
people say well you know that's stupid
why do they do that again
unless you've traded at an institutional
level
you don't a lot of traders they don't
comprehend that people say well why you
know the market's trading 39 and a
quarter
why why would i want to pay up to 40
well because if you're a big trader you
know your order is going to impact the
market you know that the market's about
to move
you just want to get grab everything as
possible as soon as possible
before the liquidity dries up or the
market starts to move
so if you're looking at a normal
footprint chart it's a little difficult
to see right you got to know what to
look for
and again having software that's going
to draw it on there and as far as i know
my software is the only one
until people start taking my ideas again
and and putting them into theirs
is it allows you to see where it's
happening right there's a sweep up here
before the market
sold off from eight points
then here for the market rallied right
but again
you have to know what to look for you
can stare at a dome try and figure it
out oh my gosh was that a sweep or did
the orders get pulled
or was it lack of liquidity or something
this is euro currency
right the chart i just showed you was
e-mini's
this is euro currency okay so it again
doesn't matter what
market you're looking at doesn't matter
what time frame you're looking at
whether it's a one-minute chart of
one five-minute chart um you're probably
not going to see on a 15-minute chart
honestly if you're looking at order flow
on a 15-minute chart there's certain
things you could look for but
generally um if you're looking at a
longer-term chart like a 15-minute chart
you're looking for areas where the
market can retrace to
rather than moves happening but
this is a euro currency right look at it
you know can you decide
quickly where it is here it is
right have software that's going to
highlight that to you here's gold
where are the traders where these big
traders
running through the market right there
so market sweeps and stacked imbalances
honestly
often overlap because they're both very
aggressive market behavior now where it
gets juicy is
when a sweep occurs and there's no
stacked imbalance right here there's
there's no stacked imbalances in these
bars
right earlier um
here there's well on this euro currency
this was a stacked imbalance over here
but the sweep led the stacked imbalance
um so
and obviously on this buy down here
there's no stacked imbalance there's
imbalances but they're not stacked on
top of each other so you would have
missed that if you're just looking for
stacked imbalances
now point of control
right point of control is something
that's very useful to a trader right and
it's the price level in the bar
with the most volume and you know people
have asked me in the past does it have
predictive value
well you know i've done a lot of time on
research
of points of control right because every
bar has one so
it's got to be some use for it and you
know whether you're you're trading
futures whether you're trading stocks or
forex and even bitcoin or cryptos
every bar is going to have a point of
control so the poc slingshot is a is
actually an indicator we programmed into
the order flows trader and it highlights
pocs that matter
pocs points of controls that can signal
potential directional moves
and again i've done a lot of research
into this and i've identified certain
points of control along with price
action relationships
and i found that when a plc acts a
certain way
relative to previous bar activity the
price action
it can be bearish or bullish okay now
every bar has a point of control
right you can see that's the area with
the most volume right that's the gray
area in each bar
but which ones matter
right and this is what our software does
we'll highlight
the ones that matter so you can see
instantly
rather than saying you know does this
one matter is this one important or not
or is this just
a normal um point of control right
because you know honestly look at this
whole chart
there's points of controls but they
don't all matter
in a sense ones that matter that are
especially important that you should be
paying attention to
are going to be highlighted again this
is gold here
right okay well which points controls
are are important i don't you know if
you're looking at it unless you know
what to look for
you're not going to see it boom right
there and look at that right before
the move boom you know these are those
bars from the trades from
06 down to o2 that you want to get in on
right you always look back
on you know if i just sold somewhere in
here and caught this bar it'd be done
for the day
and that's what having good software
will do for you right it'll
make your trading a lot easier now this
is apple
it's apple stock and you can see here
bearish point of control this is a poc
it's the poc slingshot set up i'm
talking markets going sideways
and then boom you get the bearish sign
imagine you're getting short up here 115
40. next this is on a one minute chart
we sell down 50 cents go sideways boom
another bearish sign down here
and the market just sells off nicely
this is this morning in the e-minis
right we this was about two hours ago
right we had this nice bearish poc
coming in right here
right you know right before the market
sold off into
new lows right it's nice to have
software
that will show you that stuff now
earlier i talked about value areas in a
bar
and like points of control every bar has
a value area
but certain value areas are going to be
more important than others so
you know which value areas matter right
again i was
talking earlier in this presentation
about you know looking at the gaps
between the
value areas that's that's one way but
there's other types of
value area analysis that are very
revealing
and you can see here right you got red
right what we do is we color it red if
it's bearish
we color it blue if it's bullish right
in here you can see bearish
bullish right at the low of the day you
have a nice bullish one this was that
one where you had the divergence
as well again this is on a five minute
chart
market moved up nicely
again if you're looking at a normal bar
chart
or a footprint chart you know trying to
figure out which
value areas are going to be important is
is kind of difficult
but boom you know having it highlighted
to you is just going to make your life
a lot simpler right imagine if you're
you're trading
if you imagine you're looking at a dome
right if you're a dome trader right
you're interested in order flow
because you trade on a dome having a
footprint chart on a screen next to you
saying hey you know what i've got this
bearish signal here
in the order flow okay
well you know that okay yeah i could
throw i could stack some offers in the
order book if we trade back in there
get short boom then it starts breaking
away then you got this big gap of
value right here go sideways boom
another gap right
you know this is how you're going to get
more out of a trade by watching what's
happening in the value it's not just
about
okay i want to get short i got automatic
take profit or
stop watch the order flow right if
you're short in here at
24 and then you you know you gotta
take profit you know whatever it you
call it
i don't know um 16 or something and you
see well i got a gap here
i got a gap here in the value well you
know that this market is
value is migrating lower chances are
we're going to go lower you get more out
of that trade
right that's how you use order flow to
help you
stay in winning trades longer or cut
losing trade or cut trades that are just
stalling out on you going nowhere cut
those earlier
again this is crude oil okay
we're at a low of the day we got some
divergences which is good right you got
some positive deltas you know it's kind
of worrisome in here you got one
you got 97 which is decent but it's less
than
here but points controls are moving
higher but
value area is bullish it's a nice strong
value area
so you put start putting this together
points of control is moving higher
you're seeing some buying imbalances you
got
a nice bullish value area you got
divergence yeah i could get long
but what do i get out well here you got
a sign in the order flow you got the
bearish
value area right in here and the market
sells off actually we sold off
took out this low and he actually made
new lows yesterday
buns this is this morning value areas
which value areas matter
right this is a bullish plc slingshot
right here
but right before it get a nice bullish
value area right here
we call it the eva the uh
extended value area right in here
right and boom up to new highs
nasdaq this morning the 30-second chart
all right for you
quick draw traders boom
bearish turns around comes bullish back
up a little bullish move up here
so you know it doesn't matter if you're
using you know 30 second chart a one
minute chart a five minute chart a range
based chart
um volume based chart tick based chart
you'd still be looking for the same
things here's apple
one minute chart bearish value area we
sell off boom we stop here at a bullish
value area
and make a nice move up so
this past hour hopefully you'll agree
it's been time well spent
and you know hopefully you've learned
something you know how you can apply
overflow seeing how you could apply
order flow to your trading
but honestly there's a lot of other
topics i wanted to cover but
i can't really do it you know in a quick
60-minute training session
but i have a special offer so you can
get everything you need to know about
order flow and if you act fast i got a
very special deal for you so you're
gonna be excited about
the order flows trader right the order
flows trader
3.0 runs on ninja trader eight okay
it's not available for tradestation
share charts or any other trading
platform i use
ninjatrader and it's it's stable right i
like ninjatrader a lot
um because i find it easy to use so
what the overflows trader is is my
footprint chart with 17 pre-programmed
wonderful tools i explained a couple
today like the value area
the slingshot point control the
market sweep those are just some of
those pre-programmed workflow tools in
there
and it's really very easy to set up
right you don't need templates or
anything because the defaults
are my defaults which is set for
your standard one minute e-mini chart
now if you're trading something like
mini dao
or nq you might want to change one or
two
settings but the default is good enough
for you to get started
and use it you don't really need to make
many changes
you know i hate the software that you
buy and
you got to spend six hours trying to
make heads or tails of it right
i want to keep it as easy as possible
for you
and normally i sell this for 8.99 on my
website
now what the order flows trader 3.0 does
is it takes my knowledge of trading
order flow and puts it into a program so
you can see what institutional traders
what the big traders are doing
in the market right it's kind of like
having me sitting next to you
explaining what's happening in the
market you know saying oh there's
there's some
aggressive activity here there's price
exhaustion here
there's you know divergence or there's
imbalance etc
but having order flow software is one
thing
right you still have to know how to use
it in the sense of know what to look for
in the order flow
so i don't just give you the software
and say here it is there's the software
just go try and figure out order flow by
yourself right
i give you a lot of education on how to
trade with order flow
and for example
today you're going to get access to the
order flow trading course which
i sell for 297 on my website it's 20
lessons it's 15 hours of instruction
on reading order flow you're going to
get that for free
and also you know a few years ago i
created my overflow inner circle
and there's 56 videos in it there's
advanced order flow analysis
i don't want to say tricks but you know
nuances by a better term
and tips that you can use in looking for
the order flow and just
what just this series of videos i
normally sell this for 4.97
you're gonna get it for free okay this
is the inner circle
video series so you add that up together
you got the software you got the
training
of the order flow trading course you got
the inner circle video series
that's almost seventeen hundred dollars
right that's 1693.
now it's one thing to learn from videos
and books right
and it takes discipline takes commitment
you know i see that with my kids doing
their e-learning
um you know it's hard to stay focused
you know when you're watching
a video or or you know watching a
teacher
like my kids do and you know teacher
i'll you know i'll see my teachers just
here watch this video
you know it's more helpful to have live
training where you can ask questions
participate
and for the last two years i've been
hosting live user
training sessions for users of my
software where i drive home
what i saw in the order flow over the
past week or you know different ways to
use the software that they might not
have thought of
you could ask your questions about areas
you're struggling with in your analysis
of the markets
and all the sessions are recorded so if
you can't attend you can always watch
the replay
so the archives now has i think 93 or 94
epis 92 actually i wrote here but i i
don't have last week's and tonight
is tuesday so we're having another
session tonight that you can watch
you know you can watch them at your your
leisure right
and you can see here um there's a whole
page with all the videos listed
okay and the thing that drives me nuts
is i see these people
selling software out there these gurus
you buy my software for a thousand two
thousand dollars
now you can join my training room for
another two hundred dollars a month well
for what you know you just dropped a
thousand bucks
on their software they darn well better
you know have some sort of free training
that you can go and ask questions on on
how to use their software that's why i
do
these weekly live sessions because i'm
always there right
i'm always there to to answer your
questions you know now granted if it's a
christmas holiday or something
i might not be on you might you know
it's closed we don't do it
but you know over 94 sessions over the
last two years is pretty consistent
and you know it's free it's a free
resource for you
right so you start adding it up the
software the training the videos
the weekly live training you know it's
it's pushing two thousand dollars
but you're not going to pay that right
you're just gonna pay a one-time payment
right
749 i hate these softwares that
charge you recurring you know payments
you know microsoft office you know i pay
like
ten dollars a month for them like you
know why can't they just
you know simply buy it you know you used
to be able to do that now you can't
but you know i don't want you to keep
paying and paying and paying
all right it's just a one-time simple
payment now
granted you'll have to pay your data
fees and your ninja trader fees there's
no way around your data fees you still
got to pay them but you know this
as a trader you get it for a reduced
price of uh
depending on which exchanges and which
data feed you have it you can get as low
as like seven dollars a month
if you're just watching mini s ps
so go to orderflows.com3.html
and i'll take you to the page but again
you know don't just take what i say is
you know oh my gosh mike says i should
buy it but what other users have been
saying
right sheila says your flows trader
software is very helpful
remarkably helpful because i can clearly
see now what's happening in the market
right ziad says if you really want to
trade properly and understand what on
earth is happening in the markets
order flow is the path forward right and
mike's experience an
explanation it clicks right that's why i
spent that time talking about my
background
early on is so you know that i come from
a background
a real live training background where i
traded for a living that's what i did to
pay my bills you know pay my house pay
my car pay my food
wasn't like well i was working you know
i'm an engineer and i'm trading at
nights for a couple hours a day
and this is what i have no this is how i
traded all those years
at a very high level um you know
to survive now what you do is go to
orderflows.com3 it takes you to this
page
scroll down to the bottom of the page
this is the button
you can see what you get on that page
it's a long page i don't want to go
through it all here
but just click this button to get
started right this button that says
click here to buy now
all right you're going to get you'll see
it's just a one-time payment of 749 to
get
access to the order flows trader order
flows trading course inner circle
video series and access to our weekly
live group trainings
and it takes you to paypal when you
click on that button right i don't get
your credit card i don't want your
credit card information
paypal handles it now note all the
download information the license tokens
course logins it's sent to your paypal
registered email address
so whatever email you log into paypal
with check that email for the
information
you know sometimes people have different
emails for different things right
they'll use paypal
one email and other normal
correspondence on another one
i'm not going to know what your other
email is right so please
use your check your paypal email the
email that you use
when you make payment with paypal and
yes as silly as it sounds
sometimes people are still using emails
to log into paypal that they no longer
use
um and then when i send the information
it gets bounced back but you know
just update it inside paypal the
inside of paypal but please check your
paypal
registered email address that's where
everything is going to be sent
now you'll notice here oh you don't see
it on there but you know it just takes
relatively
for your process your payment to get
processed it takes a couple hours so
it's not an instant process because we
got to go in and create license tokens
course logins and all that stuff so
you know you get it relatively quickly
generally but you know
on days that where things are are busy
markets are moving it can take a couple
hours so again it's just a one-time
payment of
7.49 go to orderflows.com off three
so you got a couple options you can do
right you can do nothing
and stay right where you are right and
sit there and say well
yeah i'm gonna be i'm waiting to start
understanding order flow right and you
sit there until you're dead you're never
gonna get it
or two you could take what you learned
today
and see if you can do it on your own
trial and error for the next few months
perhaps
if you're lucky you'll start to see some
positive results right
but you're going to go down a lot of
wrong way streets
trying to figure it out on your own
honestly and worst of all you don't want
to
try to figure it out on your own and
start losing money in the markets
because you think you understand what
you're looking at no
that's the worst possible result or
option three
you take my hand and allow us to walk
you step by step through each part of
the process
skip the trial and error if you do the
work you'll watch as your life and
trading transforms right
before your eyes right but again yeah
you still got to put in the work
right it's not all served up on a silver
platter i'd like to say yeah here it is
but at the end of the day you're a
trader you got to trade you got to make
the decisions
now a special bonus for those that are
stuck around here at investors expo is
i'll give you access to a trading course
i did called the order flow playbook
it's a nice course it's got actually 10
trade setups that are very useful for a
lot of people
um normally i sell this for 297 you're
going to get access to this free but you
got to get started now
go to orderflows.com slash off three
dot html i got to put the dot html at
the end and what you're going to get
you're going to get the order flows
trader which is normally 8.99
trading course which is normally 297.
you get access to the order flows inner
circle video series
that's normally 497. you get access
to the order flows live weekly group
training which is
you know honestly i don't know if i put
200 on here it's probably
be more right i used to do mentoring
for a lot more than 200 um
for an hour you also get access to the
order flows playbook
which is normally 297 and you're not
gonna pay the the two thousand dollars
just gonna do a one-time payment
of 7.49 now you have to go to
orderflows.com3.html
sometimes people like to find a link for
an old version
of order flows trader 2.0 which is
completely
not completely different it's the the
the older version
right this is the new version order
flows 3.0
is the latest new version this is the
one we released just literally
six weeks ago or four weeks ago rather
not six weeks ago
four weeks ago all right so this is up
to date
right and it's got the 17 pre-programmed
indicators
okay so go to orderflows.com off three
now if you want my book
go to orderflows.com
book.html all right make sure you put
the dot html
enter your name first name last name
email hit submit all right after you hit
submit it takes you to a page
where you can download the book okay
very easy so
get started go to orderflows.com off
3.html
you know but you know lastly you know
ask yourself you know i ask you what
motivates you
you know people ask you mike what
motivates you why why
you still want to work you know why why
do you want to
trade well trading gives me that freedom
to do what i want it gives me the
freedom to do
what i want with whoever i want right
for me my family is
what motivates me right this past summer
a few weeks a few months ago
we went to south dakota right as a
trader
some of the trades for himself
i could say you know what i want to take
next week off hey honey let's go take a
drive out to south dakota
okay you know that's how we do it right
like well you know sometimes we plan
things but
being able to do that on the spur of the
moment you know a lot of people don't
understand you know when i worked in
singapore
there were times where it'd be like
friday afternoon and
you know markets closed in asia and
you know i was still single one of the
guys on the desk was also single what
what are we doing this weekend you got
plans no nothing say hey let's go to
thailand
just go down hail a taxi go to the
airport get a ticket go to thailand for
the weekend why because we had that
freedom
right we could do what we want when we
wanted it
and more importantly we could afford it
right trading gives me has given me that
freedom
pretty much all my life since i've been
a traitor and you know i'd like to see
other people have that freedom right it
really
makes life enjoyable right i hated my
job sometimes
as a trader but that was the politics of
it the one thing that kept me
going was understanding what's happening
in the market because i could just tune
everything out all the politics going on
in the office i could just tune off by
watching the markets
so again to get started go to
orderflows.com
off three i put the links in the chat
so that uh you know anybody can just
click on those links get started
and you know that's that's all you know
first thing like i said you know people
say
what's the what do i got to do in life
well you gotta get started
right and and the best way to get
started is to
get software get training and start
watching the market
right so thanks everybody thanks for
taking your time off
this afternoon um i'm not gonna keep you
on much longer i've gone
for about just over an hour hopefully
you found something useful
in today's presentation that you can
apply to your training
and you know any questions shoot me an
email mike orderflows.com
and you know if you have my software
i'll be seeing you guys tonight
on the live group training session so
have a great day everybody
thank you and bye bye
you